it's no secret how far machines
artificial inteligence have come
recently face recognition cameras
worldwide battlefields filled with
remote-controlled drones I even have it
on good authority that Siri will soon be
able to differentiate between lunch and
launch that the forefront of this
technological revolution is DARPA the
Pentagon's
super-secret research arm best known for
being mentioned in far-fetched headlines
they're working on a new program that
will be able to differentiate between
fake news and real news so long as
there's no mention of the word lunch in
it the semantic forensic program will
develop technologies to automatically
detect attribute and the characterized
falsified multimodal media assets to
defending its large-scale automated
disinformation attacks now I know what
you're thinking and I agree that it can
be difficult to think up new ways to
drain the US military's six hundred
billion dollar budget but points for
creativity on the other hand this may be
an honest effort the Pentagon out of the
goodness of its heart protecting people
from disinformation that is when it
isn't spreading fake news itself like
when the Secretary of Defense had to
shut down an entire department dedicated
to disinformation and then there was the
office of strategic influence you may
recall that I went down that next day
and said fine if you want to savage this
thing fine I'll give you the corpse
there's the name you can have the name
but I'm gonna keep doing every single
thing that needs to be done and I have I
also know your next question yes a
computer which can't yet tell apart
whether that's a smile on your face or
whether you're crying in agony will now
tell you what's real and what's fake
scary and probably impossible Stanford
University recently created an algorithm
that tried to separate lies from the
truth they said it worked 82 percent of
the time and that's putting it kindly
the possibility of actually detecting
fake news
from the written word it is possible if
it is the spoken word it is a printed
word it will be very very difficult
because if you do not have the ability
to write grammatically correctly then I
imagine this system will then detect
inconsistencies and presume it is
machine written any of these machine
algorithms would take they would take
years to develop
you would have to study each individual
area and program everything in to these
algorithms the difference between the
northeast of the United States and the
southeast of the United States there are
almost different languages and let's be
honest this is DARPA we're talking about
the people who wrote off billions trying
to create such wonders as an army of
virus spreading insects weaponized bees
robotic elephants and alive poliovirus
just for the heck of it apparently never
cease to amaze when it comes to creative
ways to get to the bottom of another
multi-billion dollar budget and from the
extremely unlikely off-chance that they
succeed
well our future could kind of suck the
truth
you